MARTIN OMANDER: Hello.
My name is Martin
Omander, and I welcome you
to "Google Root Access,"
the show featuring
actionable startup advice.
My guest today is
Philip Bergqvist
from the startup
Unified Intents.
Philip, tell us a bit
about Unified Intents.
PHILIP BERGQVIST: So we're
a Swedish startup company.
We've developed an app called
Unified Remote, which today
is actually one of the top-rated
apps on the Android Play Store.
Essentially what it does
is it turns your smartphone
into a universal remote control
for your Mac, Windows or Linux
computer.
And what makes it
super easy is that you
get different remote
controls in one
app for different applications.
So if you want to control
Spotify, or VLC, or iTunes,
or even mouse or keyboard,
you can do all of this
from one app, rather
than having to use, say,
50 different apps
for all of this.
Most of our users will maybe
use their computer connected up
to their TV in
their living room,
and then be able to
sit back in their sofa
and control it using
their smartphone.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
So I went to the Play Store
and downloaded the app
and saw that it was free.
Yet, you do have revenue.
So tell me about how you
were thinking about revenue
and how you got to that point?
PHILIP BERGQVIST: So basically,
when we first released the app,
this was a couple years ago.
And we didn't really
think hey, let's
make a startup out of this,
and let's earn lots of money.
MARTIN OMANDER:
That's the best way
to start a startup, by the way.
PHILIP BERGQVIST: It was just
us, two guys, hobby project.
And we just wanted to
solve our own use case.
And so we started
off by releasing
a free version of the app.
And then just from the
traction and the response
that we got early
on, we said maybe
we can start monetizing as well.
So then we decided to release
a paid version as well.
And now we've just been
going on from there
and adding new features
here and there.
MARTIN OMANDER: So you
have two applications.
One is free and one you pay for.
And some features are
only in the paid version.
What features are only
in the paid version?
And could you tell
us a bit about what
thinking went into that?
Why did you put only
those in the paid version?
PHILIP BERGQVIST: So
one of the problems
that we notice right now is
that our free version is maybe
a bit too good.
And that's because when
we first created it,
we just added all the features
that we wanted and released it
for free.
Whereas now when we think
back, we notice that,
maybe we put in too many
free things in that version.
But now as time goes on, all
the new features that we add
go into the paid version.
So when we start adding
voice control or widgets
or quick actions,
all these features
go into the full
version instead.
And the biggest
difference between the two
is the number of remote
controls that you can use.
So in the free version,
you only get access
to 13 different remote controls,
whereas in the full version,
you have access to 70 plus
programs that you can control.
And all the new remote
controls that we add always
go into the full
version instead.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
So there are many ways to
charge premium customers,
and many startups use the
freemium model like you do.
You have picked the
approach of having
two applications, a
free and a paid one.
Why did you choose
that approach?
PHILIP BERGQVIST: So
actually when we started out,
there wasn't in-app
purchases for Android.
So this was really the
best approach for us.
We released the free version
and then a separate app,
which is the paid version.
We have in-app
purchases on iPhone,
and we've seen that's been
really successful so far.
So that's definitely
something that we're
looking into adding for the
Android version as well.
MARTIN OMANDER: So you
see that in-app purchases
are successful.
You mean that there's a
greater conversion rate,
or in what way are
they successful?
PHILIP BERGQVIST: Yeah.
So we actually see a
greater conversion rate.
I don't know if
that is specifically
due to in-app
purchases, or it may
be differences in the
different platforms.
But at the end of
the day, it makes
it easier for our users to
take the step of upgrading.
And obviously, that's what
we should be doing, make
it easier for our users to find
what features they can buy,
and if they want
them, to easily do it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
Because if you have
to exit the app,
go and find the app
again, download it, pay,
you lose context that you want
to guide the user through.
So how much do you
charge for the paid app?
And why did you pick
that particular price?
PHILIP BERGQVIST: So
the paid app is $3.99.
We just looked around at the
App Store or the Play Store,
and had a look.
The category that we want
to be in, that's Tools.
We looked at maybe
similarly complex apps.
And then we found $3.99,
that probably works.
And we've gone with that, and
it's worked well for us so far.
MARTIN OMANDER: Have
you experimented
with higher or lower pricing?
PHILIP BERGQVIST: Yeah.
So from time to time, we'll do
a campaign, maybe at a one year
or second year
anniversary of the app.
We'll do a campaign where we
discount the app to just $1.00.
And then, we see massive boosts
during a short period of time.
I don't think that would be
very profitable in the long run.
I think it's good that we
have our $4.00 price point.
But it is interesting
to experiment and see
what happens when we
change the price, which
is super easy to do through
the developer console.
MARTIN OMANDER: So you
see a massive boost
when you lower the
price to $0.99.
Why don't you keep the price
down there all the time
and get the boost all the time?
PHILIP BERGQVIST: So what we
see is when we lower the price,
there's a lot of
media recognition.
So there are sites that
just scrape the Play Store
and look for apps that
change their prices.
So when we lower the price,
there's a big buzz around it.
But then eventually,
after a couple days maybe,
it starts to die off a bit.
And I think in the
long run, I don't
think we'd be as profitable
with a lower price.
But it's super
difficult to know.
MARTIN OMANDER: So by doing
that, lowering the price
repeatedly and then
taking it back up,
you can get that media
hit several times.
PHILIP BERGQVIST:
We try not to put it
into too much of a system.
We don't think it's a good way
of maybe marketing our app.
But from time to time,
it's fun to give our fans
a bit of a treat
from time to time.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
Very good.
So many startups,
perhaps even most today,
try to do the freemium model.
What advice would
you give to them?
What would you have
done differently,
and what has been
successful for you?
PHILIP BERGQVIST: So I think
it's a very good technique when
starting out to have a
free version of an app.
Obviously, it's maybe
easier to get new users,
get traction early on with a
free app versus a paid app,
where maybe you don't
have a lot of reviews.
Maybe people don't really
know about you yet.
So that's worked
really well for us.
We built up a relatively big
user base on our free version
before we even
launched our paid app.
It was about one year
difference there.
But also as I
mentioned before, a bit
of a problem we're seeing now is
that our free version is maybe
a bit too good.
So if you are a
startup and you're
thinking that you might want
to monetize in the future,
maybe think a bit
about what features
do we want to have in
the free app right now?
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
Well, great.
Thank you very much for sharing
experiences with us, Philip.
PHILIP BERGQVIST: Yeah.
Thanks.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hopefully, you
found something useful here
that you can apply
in your startup.
If you have comments, please
enter them in the YouTube
comments section.
We read everything you write.
And finally, if you're a
high-tech entrepreneur,
go to
developers.google.com/startups
to find out how
Google can help you.
That's it.
See you next time.
All right. [SPEAKING SWEDISH]
PHILIP BERGQVIST:
[SPEAKING SWEDISH]